Salut à tous, aujourd’hui c'est dimanche c'est donc le jour de l'explication de la semaine
C'est le jour où je vous apprend à bluffer vos amis
comme ça fait longtemps que je ne vous ai pas expliqué un tour de carte
bien c'est ce que je vais faire ce dimanche, je vais vous apprendre
un des meilleurs tours de carte que je pense que vous puissiez apprendre aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce qu'il n'y a pas de manipulation, parce que c'est indétectable,
in-remontable comme on dit dans le milieu des magiciens
Oui il y a un milieu des magiciens
En clair, c'est le tour idéal
en parlant d'idéal. L'idéal ça aurait été que je puisse le faire sur quelqu'un pour que vous ayez la démonstration
ce qu'on appelle la démo, en fait, du tour avant de vous expliquez ça et cette technique
euh... malheureusement j'ai pas de vidéo de ça
Oui alors forcément vous vous dites "Pourquoi il explique pas des choses qui fait dans le MentalVlog habituellement"
et oui c'est une très bonne question, vous avez été 2-3 à la poser sur différentes vidéos dans les commentaires
Pourquoi je ne vous explique pas ce que je fais dans le MentalVlog
que ce soit en technique de mentalisme ou en magie.
Et bien simplement parce que tout ce que je vous explique le dimanche ce sont des choses que vous pouvez reproduire
en fait
Et ça c'est l'intérêt. Si on y réfléchi bien ça sert à rien de donner une Ferrari à quelqu'un qui est en train de passer le code
Je ne veux pas vous donner des trucs pour vous donner des trucs.
Je veux vraiment qu'il y est une notion d'apprentissage
Ensemble
Nous sommes en train de passer un contrat ensemble
Un contrat... moral *rires* je dis n'importe quoi
Non il y a pas de contrat mais vous voyez ce que je veux dire la démarche, c'est à dire que ce que je vous apprends dans l'explication du dimanche
C'est quelques choses que vous pourrez faire dans la semaine, pour bluffer les gens
et ça c'est... et ça c'est sur contrat
Voilà je vous le signe ici
Moyennant un petit peu de travail de votre part
que ce soit en terme de technique ou de présentation faut forcément que vous bossiez un petit peu dans votre coin
Pour pouvoir faire quelques choses de présentable
Olala il serait pas en train de vous prendre la tête le dimanche Olicard
C'est vrai je suis fatigué, du coup j'ai l'impression de faire des leçons de moral
On s'en fout
Il n'y a pas de leçon de moral j'ai juste envie de faire l'explication du dimanche
pour ce MentalVlog
L'idée est la suivante
Vous avez un jeu de carte complet ça c'est important il faut qu'il y ai toutes les cartes dedans
Vous le faites mélanger à votre spectateur
Le spectateur mélange le jeu. Une fois qu'il a mélangé. Il prends une carte
Lui même. Il a le jeu dans les mains. Il vous rend le paquet
et vous vous retournez le temps qu'il regarde la carte
Il essaie d'en faire une belle image mentale
qu'il la fasse voir à tous ces amis etc...
Une fois que c'est fait il la met dans sa poche
il la cache sur lui admettons
Vous vous retournez. Vous discutez avec lui sur le fait qu'il vous est impossible de connaitre, pour le moment, de connaitre quelle carte il a choisi
et quelques secondes après, à peine, vous vous êtes déjà en possession de l'information de la carte, qu'il a
Intriguant non ?!
Après la suite du tour elle dépend de vous
c'est qu'une question de présentation, c'est un peu vous qui décidez ce que vous allez faire avec
Soit vous décidez de révéler la carte qu'il a choisi. Puisque vous en avez connaissance
et il la sort de sa poche et Bim on vérifie et c'est bon
Fin possible n°2, vous pouvez jouer au mentaliste. Vous pouvez faire votre petit Fabien Olicard
et faire semblant de lire les réactions sur son visage
pour dire quelle carte il a choisi
ça fonctionne aussi
ça reste de la magie
Soit vous faites ça cette option n°2
mais en même temps vous vous entraînez réellement à chercher les réactions sur son visage
pour savoir quelle carte il a choisi, vous vous êtes déjà en possession de l'information
donc vous pouvez voir vraiment comment la personne réagit
Ça vous apprend à connaitre les réactions de cette personne
Très intéressant
Et afin autre possibilité, la dernière mais qui est la plus ouverte en terme de sous piste
Vous lui faite remettre la carte dans le jeu, vous lui faites mélanger le jeu
et vous, vous récupérez le jeu
et vous pouvez révéler la carte de la manière de votre choix
Par exemple, si la carte était le roi de ♣. Vous prenez le jeu
Vous allez jusqu'au Roi de ♣
Vous séparez le jeu en 2
comme ceci
Vous reposez la partie inférieur dessus sur le paquet
et là le Roi de ♣ est en 1ère position
et vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez
Un petit claquement de doigt
un petit je mentalise le paquet
non mentaliser c'est moi qui dit ça
Votre formule magique quelconque
et en tout cas la carte sera sur le dessus
En fait,
tout est possible après
puisque vous savez quelle carte il a choisi
Comment faire ça? Je sais que je vous soûle à tout vous expliquer là
et la fin et la finalité, les trucs possibles
mais quand je vais vous révéler, en fait la manière de procéder
Je ne veux pas que vous soyez déçu, en fait, et que vous allez pas plus loin
C'est très intéressant
C'est sûrement l'une des techniques que j'ai utilisé qui m'as le plus servi
Je ne sais pas de qui elle est cette technique
si quelqu'un l'a déjà utiliser, je suppose que oui, en fait, je dois pas être le seul à avoir penser ça
J'ai pas de source à vous donner du coup de ce côté là
Mais je ne dois pas être le seul à avoir penser à faire ça
Attention je vais vous révéler ce que c'est
Il s'agit
*roulement de tambour*
De compter les cartes
Compter
[En Rigolant] Dis donc comme c'est étonnant Fabien
avec toi on passe notre temps à compter
ou à faire des images dans sa tête
Oui, c'est vrai. Mais c'est pratique
alors
Ne vous enfuyez pas, quand même, ne coupez pas la vidéo tout de suite
Il y a une méthodologie qui est très simple pour ça
Dans un jeu de carte, il y a 52 cartes.
26 noires et 26 rouges
13 de chaque famille
et avec ces informations là, on peut retrouver rapidement la carte
pour vous expliquer je vais vous fait la démonstration en même temps
Je mélange également le jeu comme ça je ne sais pas dans quel ordre sont les cartes
Je prend une carte au hasard
Je ne vous la fait pas voir parce que je pourrais la voir dans l'écran
du coup je vais la poser juste ici.
Ah non, pas sur le dessus parce que vous allez pas la voir
juste là
Et imaginons que ce soit le spectateur en fait qui soit derrière moi qui vient de prendre la carte. OK?
donc je lui tourne le dos
dès que je lui tourne le dos, je vais commencer à passer les cartes en revue
et je vais compter toutes les noires
parce que c'est la 1ère qui il y a là
je vais les compter rapidement dans ma tête
en les poussant, un coup par 3, un coup par 2. Ça va très vite à compter
c'est à dire que si je pousse comme ça,
ça fait 3
2, là j'ai déjà 5
et je passe tout ensuite dans ma main droite pour tout éliminer
hop 2
là il y en a 1, 2, 3
donc ça, ça me fait 10
ensuite 3 et 2 ça fait 5. Donc 15
2 puis on cherche 3 pour aller à 20
là j'en ai 2, puis 1, 2, 3 ça m'emmène à 25
et là j'ai la 26ème qui est ici
donc en passant, à vitesse réel avec un tout petit peu t'entrainement
Si vous vous entraînez un petit peu ça ira très vite
je peux passer les cartes à cette vitesse là
et assez rapidement déterminé
qu'il y a 26 noires,
Si il y a 26 noires ça veut dire que c'est une rouge qui manque
Là, je vais relancer mon spectateur
C'est à ce moment que je vais lui dire
Fais toi une belle image mentale, montre la aux autres personnes je veux vraiment que tu puisses visualiser la carte correctement
une fois que j'ai dis ça, sur ces quelques secondes
je vais essayer de déterminer la famille si c'est du ♥ ou du ♦
donc je reprend mon jeu en main
je repousse les cartes
et là ma 1ère c'est du ♥
donc je compte les ♥ je cherche pas à comprendre
Ça me fait 2
3, 4, 5, 6
7, 8
9, 10, 11, 12, 13
13 ♥ ça veut dire que c'est une carte à ♦ qui manque
Quand bien même je m'arrêterai là, j'aurai quand même une précieuse information
c'est à dire que parmi 52 cartes au départ
je ne sais pas laquelle il avait choisi
Maintenant je sais
parmi 13 cartes
c'est plus beaucoup 13 cartes
mais va falloir que je me retourne à un moment donné
donc je me retourne
vers mon spectateur
mais du coup je reste vers vous, évidemment
et là j'ai plus qu'à déterminer quelle carte, il manque à ♦
Là il y a plusieurs méthodes, plusieurs pistes possible
On compare les fortes et les faibles
Moi personnellement, je préfère faire les paires et les impaires
Je vous explique:
Je vais compter rapidement tous les cartes paires ou impaires
Si vous avez le temps, si il y a beaucoup de monde
qu'il met beaucoup de temps à montrer sa carte aux autres personnes
que ça parle beaucoup
tant mieux
vous faites ça le temps que vous avez le dos tournait
Si vous êtes retournés vous le faite en live
en lui expliquant que j'ai aucune possibilité de savoir qu'elle était sa carte
Je vais les mettre comme ça légèrement en side it externe
en side it externe c'est à dire en décalage
toutes vers le haut qu'elle soit pair ou impaire
Le valet pour moi c'est une carte impair, le roi aussi
parce que c'est la 11ème et le roi la 13ème carte
et l'As aussi c'est une carte impair
donc là pour l'instant j'en ai 2. Il y a que 6 cartes paires sur les 13 cartes évidemment
donc là j'en ai 2 qui sont passées.
5 et 6 avec la dame qui compte pour 12
donc je sais que c'est une impair
donc c'est ou l'As ou le 3 ou le 5 ou le 7 ou le 9 ou le valet ou le roi
et rien que le fait de les avoir passer, je peux déjà vous dire que c'est le 3 qui manque
Si j'étais pas sûr, j'essayerai juste de repasser le jeu pour faire
As
là je rechercherai le 3 mais je le trouverai pas
par contre je trouve bien le 5
le 7
le Valet
et le Roi
et le 9 évidemment je sais pas parce que je le voyais pas
donc je sais que c'est le 3 ♦ qu'il y a ici
Je pense que tout ça, ça vous parait un petit peu confus parce qu'on a l'impression qu'on met beaucoup de temps à le faire
avec un petit peu d'entrainement, pas beaucoup, vous saurez le faire
de plus en plus rapidement et plus vous le ferez et plus vous serez rapide
c'est ça qui est intéressant.
Autre avantage, ça fait encore bosser votre cerveau
pour avoir une capacité en fait, de faire plusieurs choses en même temps
Tout en comptant mentalement,
vous allez même réussir à terme à parler tout en comptant
Je vous en fait une autre petite démonstration très rapide pour que vous voyez le temps que ça prend
On met une carte ici
on la regarde pas
et là je ne vous parle plus pour que vous voyez vraiment à la vitesse réelle
je me retourne du spectateur, je compte les cartes
Je vais compter avec vous comme ça vous le verrez
C'est une noire qui manque. Ok
On fait le retour
C'est du ♠
et comme j'ai l'habitude j'ai déjà commencé à repérer  les ♠
Je suis allé un petit peu vite mais je pense que c'est l'As de ♠
Et c'est l'As de ♠
Je suis content. Moi je suis toujours content quand je réussi quelques choses dans la vie
Dans la vie en générale, je suis content
Voilà j'espère que ça va vous donner envie de travailler ça. Parce que c'est pas une grande technique
C'est une technique plus mentale que de dextérité, de manipulation
mais rappelez vous ce que je vous disais au début de la vidéo
Ça vous ouvre plein de pistes de finalités
Ça vous permet de... d'être toujours prêt, en fait, avec un tour
La seule contrainte,
il faut que le jeu est bien c'est 52 cartes. C'est important
et oui parce que sinon ça va vous induire en erreur
Forcément
J'espère que cette explication du dimanche, vous a plu
et que vous allez pouvoir le travailler
pour bluffer des gens, peut être dès cette semaine
Entraînez vous de toute manière il n'y a pas de secret pour que ça rentre
Eh, eh, il faut s’entraîner
Merci d'être toujours de plus en plus nombreux à regarder ce MentalVlog
Voilà ça me fait plaisir. Ben oui évidemment je vois les vus qui montent, je vois le nombre d'abonnés qui montent
ça veut dire que vous êtes prévenues des vidéos, que vous marquez un intérêt
Ça veut dire aussi que ça aide à faire connaitre la chaîne. J'ai de plus en plus d'abonnés tous les jours
Ça c'est grâce à vos partages
Plus vous partagez les vidéos, ben forcément plus il y a de gens qui découvrent la chaîne
Continuez
C'est tout ce que j'ai à vous dire c'est super chouette
Vous pouvez vous abonner d'ailleurs en cliquant juste là aussi, dans chaque vidéos
Il y a le petit logo qui est là
Vous pouvez venir me voir sur scène en spectacle pour vous faire mentaliser
pour de vrai, soit durant les hallucinations collectives. La prochaine c'est le 28 mars 2016
soit dans mon spectacle Fabien Olicard vous mentalise
il y a toutes les dates de tournée sur mon site:
fabienolicard.fr
Les prochaines dates c'est à Mulhouse, à l'entrepot théâtre
Si vous venez on prendra le temps de faire une vidéo à la fin pour le MentalVlog en fait
comme vous en avez déjà vu
En attendant, merci beaucoup pour les likes pour les petits pouces en l'air.
Merci pour les commentaires. Je les lis, j'y répond. Je... je prend tellement de plaisir avec vous et grâce à vous voilà
je suis dans ma phase de merci en fait
Voilà Merci merci merci
Passez un excellent dimanche et rendez vous demain lundi pour le prochain MentalVlog
Ciao!